okay so async I oh right the concurrent
Python programmers dream it's the answer
to everyone's asynchronous prayers right
the async IO module has various layers
of abstraction allowing developers as
much control as they need and are
comfortable with simple hello world like
examples do show how how it can be so
simple but it's easy to get lulled into
a false sense of security and these sort
of hello world examples aren't that
helpful over we're led to believe that
we can do a lot with the structured
async in a wait API layer some tutorials
well great for the developer to get
their toes wet I'm try to illustrate
real-world examples but are actually
just beefed up hello world examples some
tutorials even misuse the async i/o
interface I'm aligned one to easily fall
into the depths of callback hell and
there are some tutorials that will get
you easily up and running and I'm with
async IO but then you may not realize
that it's not exactly correct or not
what you want or it only gets you part
of the way there and while some
tutorials and walkthroughs do a lot to
improve upon the basic like hello world
use case and maybe it's just still just
a web crawler I'm not sure about others
but I'm not really building bug crawlers
at Spotify
um I've built services that do you need
to make a lot of HTTP requests sure and
they need to be non-blocking but these
services of mine they also have to react
to pubsub events to measure progress of
actions initiated from those pups of
events handle any incomplete actions or
other external errors deal with pub/sub
message lease management and measure
service level indicators and send
metrics and we need to do this with non
async io friendly dependencies so for me
my problem got difficult quickly i'm so
allow me to provide you a real world
example that actually comes from the
real world has anyone heard of Netflix's
chaos monkey I see some hands so a few
years ago at Spotify we built something
similar like a chaos creating service
that does periodic hard restarts of our
entire fleet of instances and so we're
gonna do the same here a service called
mayhem mandrel no pun off chaos monkey
which we will listen for a pup sub
message and restart a host based off of
that message and so as we build this
service I'll point out best practices
that I may or may not have realized and
when first using async I own and this
will essentially become the type of
resource that pathline would have wanted
about like three years ago
and again don't worry about the code in
the slides I'll have a link and referred
that refers to all the code at the end
so we're gonna start with some
foundational code we're gonna write a
simple publisher so here's where we're
gonna start we have a while true loop we
have a unique ID for each message to
publish to our queue I want to highlight
that we're not going to await the cube
put of a message an async IO dot create
task will actually schedule a cartoon on
the loop without blocking the rest of
our for loop the create task method does
return a task object but we can also use
it as sort of a fire-and-forget
mechanism if we added the weight here
everything after this and within the
published care routine will be blocked
this isn't an issue with our current
setup but it could be if we were to
limit the size of our queue and then
that a weight would be awaiting on space
to free up in the cube so we're just
gonna stick with the async i/o create
task so we have a publisher co-routine
function and now we need a similar
consumer so this consumer will consume
the messages that we've published it's
sort of similar to the publisher now we
have a while true loop and a weight on
the queue for a message but here we
don't want to create a task of queue get
it makes sense to block the rest of the
care routine on this because there isn't
much
if there are no messages to consume I
want to highlight this again we're only
blocking within the scope of the consume
care routine we're not blocking the
actual event loop so let's replace a
cinco dot sleep with a function that
will restart a host and I'm sure it
looks like I'm just like pushing the
simulation of i/o work to the restart
host function but in doing so I'm
actually able to create a task out of it
so therefore we're not blocking on
awaiting for more messages perhaps we
want to do more than one thing per
message and for example in addition to
restarting a host maybe we'd like to
store that message in a database for
potential replaying later as well so
we'll make use of async ioad create
tasks again for the safeco routine to
schedule on the loop basically checking
it over to the loop to execute when it
can and in this example the two tasks of
restarting and saving don't need to
depend on one another and I'm completely
sidestepping the potential concern or
complexity of should we restart a host
if we can't save to the database and
vice versa but maybe you actually want
your work to happen serially you may not
you may not want to have concurrency for
some asynchronous tasks so for instance
maybe you restart hosts that have an
uptime of more than seven days so this
is similar to like within banking you
should check the balance of an account
before you actually debit it and so
needing code to be serial or sequential
to have steps or dependencies it doesn't
mean that you can't be asynchronous the
wait last restart date will yield to the
loop but that doesn't mean that restart
hosts will be the next thing on that
loop that the loop executes it will just
allow other things to happen outside of
this co-routine so with that in mind I
will just put all this message related
logic into a separate co-routine so we
don't block the consumption of messages
I'm saving a message shouldn't block a
restart host if needed so well so we'll
return to it being a task and then we're
just going to remove the uptime check
and just restart hosts indiscriminately
because why not well so we pulled the
message from the queue in fan fanned out
work based off of that message and now
we need to perform like finalization
work on that message and so often with
pub/sub technologies if you don't
acknowledge a message within a
predefined time frame it will get
redelivery so for a finalization task we
should acknowledge the message so it
isn't redeliver do you currently have
two separate tasks save and restart host
and we want to make sure that they are
both done before the message is cleaned
up we could go back to the sequential
awaits since that's a very direct way of
manipulating the ordering but we can
also use a callbacks on a completed task
now what we therefore one is somehow to
have a task that wraps around the two
co-routines of like save and restart
host since we have to wait for both to
finish before we can clean for cleaning
up can happen we can make use of async
i/o gather which returns a future like
object and to which we can attach the
callback of cleanup via add done
callback we can now just await that
future in order to kick off the save and
restart house care routines and then
obviously the call bag of cleanup will
be called once those two are done and so
visualizing this a bit you can see that
both the save and the restart care
routine are complete and then the
cleanup will be called to signify that
the message is actually completely done
and we've also maintain appropriate
concurrency and I don't you but I have
an allergy to callbacks so um perhaps we
also need cleanup to be non-blocking and
so then we can just actually await clean
after a waiting gather itself
which i think is that gun much cleaner
looking so to quickly review a sink is
pretty easy to use but being easy
doesn't being easy to use doesn't
automatically mean that you're using it
correctly you can't just throw around a
sink and await keywords around blocking
code sort of a shift in the mental
paradigm with then needing to think
about what work can be farmed out and
let its do its thing and then what
dependencies are there and where code
might still need to be sequential but
having your steps within your code like
having first a then B and then C may
seem like it's blocking and when it's
not sequential code can still be
asynchronous and for instance I might
have have to call customer service for
something and wait to be taken off hold
for them but while I wait I can put the
phone on speaker and like pet my super
needy cat so I might be single-threaded
as a person but I can still like
multitask and so often you'll want your
service to gracefully shut down if it
receives a signal of some sort like
cleaning up open database connections
I'm stop consuming new messages finished
responding to current requests while not
accepting any new requests that kind of
thing so if we happen to restart an
instance of our own service and we
should probably clean up the mess that
we've made before exiting completely out
so here's some typical boilerplate code
to get service running and we have a
queue instance and setting up the loop
scheduling the pub the publish and the
consume tasks and then starting the
Advanta maybe you even catch the
commonly known like keyboard interrupt
exception so if we run it as is and then
send it the term or in single we see
that we do get to that except in that
finally block with these two log lines
however if we send our program a single
other than Segen to like sig term we see
that we don't actually reach that
finally clock
where we're logging that we're closing
up the loop and it should also be
pointed out that even if we were to only
ever expect a SIGINT signal or a
keyboard interrupt signal and it could
happen outside of the catching of
exception potentially causing the
service to end up in an incomplete or
otherwise unknown state so instead of
catching keyboard interrupt we can use a
signal handler on the loop itself so
first we define our shutdown behavior
echo routine that will be responsible
for doing all of our unnecessary
shutdown tasks here I'm just like
closing database connections returning
messages as not Act so that they can be
delivered and not dropped and then
cleaning up or collecting all
outstanding tasks except for the
shutdown task itself and then canceling
them we don't necessarily need to cancel
pending tasks we could just collect them
and allow them to finish and we may also
want to take this opportunity to flesh
any collected metrics so that they're
not lost so then let's add our shutdown
curtain function to the event loop so
the first thing we do is is set up our
loop first and then add our signal
handler with the desired signals that we
want to respond to and then remove the
keyboard interrupt
so then running this again and we
actually do see that we get to that
finally Clause now you might be
wondering which signals to react to and
apparently there is no standard and
basically you should be aware of how
you're running your service and handle
accordingly and it seems like it could
get particularly muscled messy with
conflicting signals and when adding
docker to the mix another misleading API
and async i/o is a shield method and so
the docs say that it's meant to shield a
future from cancellation but he had a
care team that must not be cancelled
during shutdown
I say kayo Dutch shield will not help
you so this is because the tasks in a
sink I do Dutch shield creates creates
like that task that gets created gets
included in a sink I own all tasks and
therefore receives the cancellation
signal and just like the rest rest of
the tasks so to help illustrate this a
little bit and have a simple like a sing
function with a long sleep that then
like finally logs aligned sang done and
we had to shield it from cancellation so
as for the docks we have like a parent
co-routine shielding the care team to
get canceled and so the the task that is
running the parent Tessa is running the
shielded care routine if that's if
that's cancelled it shouldn't affect the
shielded care routine and so then we add
our parent tasks to our main sort of
function and then we're running this and
interrupting it after a second we see
that we don't actually get to the done
log line and that it's immediately
cancelled even if our shut down care
routine function
skips cancelling the shield curtain or
even a parent tasks it still ends up
getting cancelled so basically we don't
really have any nurseries and they think
I accord and clean ourselves up it is
upon us to to be responsible and close
up connections and files that were open
and I respond to outstanding requests
basically leave things how we found them
doing our cleanup in the finally Clause
isn't enough though since the signal
could be sent outside of the try except
Clause so as we construct our loop we
should tell how the loop should be
deconstructed as soon as possible in the
program to ensure that all of our bases
are covered
we also want to be aware of when our
program could be shut down which is
closely tied to how we run our program
if it's a manual script and then again
is fine but if it's like a demonize
within a demonized docker container and
then sig term might be more appropriate
and finally if you use shield in a
service that has
signal handler you should be be aware of
its funky behavior and so you might have
noticed that we're not doing any
handling of exceptions so far let's
revisit our care routine or restart host
care routine and we're gonna add like a
super-realistic exception so running
this we do see that the super serious
exception is raised but we actually get
a task exception was never retrieved and
this is proud that this is because we
don't properly handle the results of a
task when it raises we can do is define
sort of a global exception handler this
is super simple or super ear like
simplified and then attach it to our
loop and similar to signal handling and
so if we were to rerun this and we do
see that that logging of exception that
we are actually handling that but
perhaps you want to treat exceptions
more specifically from certain tasks and
it's good to have an exception handling
on a global level but also on a more
specific level so let's revisit our
handle a message care routine say for
instance you're fine with just logging
when a save message fails but you want
to nak or not acknowledge the pub/sub
message and put it back to the queue if
you retry the whole message if restart
fails
so since async ioad gather returns
results and we can add more of a
fine-grain exception handler to this and
handle the results as we wish I want to
highlight that setting return exceptions
to true is a super imperative here and
otherwise exceptions will be handled by
the default handler that is set
so be sure that there's some sort of
exception handling either globally
individually or a mix most probably a
mix otherwise exceptions may go
unnoticed our cause weird behavior I
also personally like using async code
either because the order of returned
results are deterministic but it's easy
to get tripped up with it by default it
will swallow exceptions but happily
continue working on other tests that
were given if the exception is never
returned then weird behavior can't
happen alright um sometimes you need to
work with threads I'm sorry just like a
threaded pub/sub like a threaded pub/sub
client and you might want to consume a
message on one thread and then handle
the message within with an occur routine
on the main event loop so let's first
attempt to use the async i/o API that
we're familiar with and update our
synchronous callback function with
creating a task V via a single create
task from the handle message care
routine that we defined earlier and then
we call a a threaded consume function
via a thread pool executor but we don't
get very far at this point we're in
another thread and there's no loop
running on that thread it's only on the
main thread so if we take what we have
right now an update or function to use
the main event loop we actually do get
it working or it looks like it worked
but it's this is deceptive we're sort of
lucky that it works some folks can
probably already see that we're not
being thread safe so instead of a loop
to create tasks we should be using async
ayahs thread safe api hein the ven care
routine thread safe um it can be
difficult to tell when you're not being
thread safe particularly when it looks
like it works
as I did in our previous attempt but in
a bit I'll actually show you how to
easily surface when there's an issue of
thread safety so my opinion it isn't too
difficult to work with threaded code and
you think I own particularly are similar
to how we work with non an async code in
the async world and we just make use of
a thread pool executor which essentially
creates an avoidable for us however it's
difficult to work with both threads in a
single when there's some sort of shared
state between between a thread in the
main loop and and so if you must then
use the thread safety P is that async IO
gives you and it took me a very long
time to realize that this existed
alright now on to testing so for a more
simplistic starting point we're going to
test a single code before we introduce
threading so to start simple we're going
to test the save co-routine using PI
test since I'm say the save is a
co-routine our tests will need to run
the care routine in the event loop so
like so which python 3 7 makes it easy
for us with async I up run or with older
python 3 versions we have to construct
and deconstruct the loop yourself but
there is a better way so there's a PI
test plug-in called PI test async IO
that will essentially do that hard work
for you oops and then all you need to do
is mark the particular tasks that are
testing async code with a decorator from
that plug-in as well as make make it so
that the test function itself is
actually a care routine function and so
now when running the tests the plug-in
will essentially do the work for you of
constructing and deconstructing the
event loop
and the PI test a single plug-in and we
can't get you pretty far but it doesn't
help you when you need to mock out
co-routines
so for instance our save co-routine
function calls another co-routine
function and they sing care you don't
sleep or maybe some actual call to a
database you don't actually want to wait
for a Cinco de up sleep to complete or
you don't actually want a connection to
the database to happen I'm so both the
unit tests mock and the PI tests mock
libraries do not support asynchronous
mocks and so we're gonna have to work
around this a bit and so first we do
make use of the PI test mock library and
we create a PI test fixture that is
essentially returning a function the
outer function itself returns the inner
function as a fixture that we'll use in
our tests and then the inner function is
basically creating and returning a mock
object and that we'll use in our tests
as well as a stub co-routine that will
that the mock will end up calling it
also patches if needed and the curtain
function with the stub so we can avoid a
network call Sleeps etc so then we're
going to create another pi pi test
fixture that will use the create code
mock fixture to mock and patch a snake I
don't sleep and we don't need the stub
co-routine and that it returns so we can
just essentially throw that away and
they're gonna use the mocks a fixture in
our test save function so we've done
here basically is patched async code up
sleep with her within our mayhem module
with the stub co-routine function then
we just assert that the mock mock two
async I would sleep object is called
and when mayhem dot save is called
because now we have a mock object
instead of an actual care routine we can
do anything that is supported with your
standard mock objects like a third
called once with setting return values
and side-effects
so it's pretty simple I guess it's um
but maybe you want to test code that has
that cause create tasks mmm and we can't
simply use the create code remote
fixture however with this for instance
let's revisit our consume care routine
which creates and schedules a task on
the loop out of handle message we first
need to create a couple of fixtures on
the for the cue that gets passed in my
first real mock and patch async io q
class in our module and then we'll use
that ma q fixture and another one Amaka
get fixture so unlike our mock sleep
fixture we will use the stub care
routine that create code mock returns
and then set it to the mock you get
nothing so here's our test consume
function where we're giving our newly
created fixtures so let's try to use the
create color mock to mock and and and
patch the call to handle message and be
a co routine curtain via a create task
note that we're setting the mock get
side-effect to one real value and one
exception to make sure that we're not
permanently stuck in that while loop and
I want and finally we want to assert
that the mock for handle message has
been called after or consume has been
run so when running this we see that
mock handle message is it's not actually
called like we're expecting and this is
because the scheduled tasks are only
scheduled at this point and impending
and we sort of need to nudge them along
so we can do this by calling collecting
all running tasks but it's not the test
itself and running them explicitly this
is a bit clunky
I know if you use the unit test from
standard library and there is a package
called an async test that handles us
better and exhausts via scheduled tasks
for you
so I hear that you're wanting like 100%
test coverage which is great um but it
might be difficult for our main function
and we need to set up signal handling
and exception handling and we need to
create a few tasks and then start and
close the loop and we can't exactly use
the event loop fixture that PI test a
single you know library gives us as it
is now we need to sort of manipulate the
event loop that high test a single will
use to when it injects it into the
tested code so what we do is update the
testing event loop and we can override
the closed behavior and if we close the
loop during the test we will lose access
to the exception and signal handlers
that we set up within the main function
so we actually want to close the loop
after we're done with the test and then
we can also use the mock to assert that
our main function actually closes the
loop so now we'll write a test main
function that actually borders on an
integration in our functional test you
want to make sure that in addition to
expecting calls to publish and consume
that shutdown gets called when expected
but we can't exactly mock out shut down
with a create cairo mock since it will
patch it we'll patch it with just
another care routine and therefore run
the mock care routine each time it
receives a signal rather than canceling
the tasks and stopping the loop so
instead we're gonna mock out what's
called with the shutdown care routine
the async i/o dot gather and then here
I'm starting a thread that will actually
send the process I signal after a tenth
of a second and so after the starting
the thread we then called
main function that we want to test so
looking at the second half of the test
we can assert that the loop setup is the
way that we expected as well as our mock
tap functions having been called
returning to the the set up the first
half of the test here you might want to
parameterize the test function itself
to test not just the second signal but
all the signals that we're expecting and
probably tests with a signal that you're
not expecting like sick user or
something like that so basically the
TLDR of using pipe is to use PI test
async Ione and there's also a package
called async test for a unit test that
functions similarly to a PI test async I
am and the bonus is that it will exhaust
the tasks schedule and loop for you
automatically as well as provide care
routine mocks so right we're decent
programmers and have code coverage but
sometimes ship breaks and we can figure
out what's going on and we can use
everyone's favorite debugger and
printing even if you won't admit it so
if you have like one tiny little thing
to debug you can use the print stack
method on the instance and so when when
you run this it will print the stack for
you for each running task you can also
increase the number of frames that are
printed as well but you probably will
actually use and will need to use async
iOS debug mode and within the standard
library itself so along with setting our
logging level to debug we can easily
turn on a sink iota bug mode while we
run our script if we didn't have a
proper exception handling setup and we'd
get information about which task is
affected and and also what's called what
is called a source trace back that gives
us more context in addition to like our
normal trace back and so without debug
mode and we get told that there's an
exception that's not properly handled
but with debug mode and it gives us an
additional clues as to what's what might
be going on and where they might be
another very handy thing that I wish I
knew of a few years ago is that if you
have threads and an event loop
interacting with each other
debug mode will surface
not being thread-safe as as a runtime
error and just quit out super helpful
one also a really nice feature about
nominees think iOS debug mode is how it
kind of acts like a tiny profiler that
will log async calls that are slower
than 100 milliseconds so we can fake a
curve routine by putting a blocking call
to with time dot sleep and so when we
run the script and we can see that it
will surface slow to finish tasks
potentially highlighting and necessarily
blocking call the default for what's
considered slow is 100 milliseconds but
that is easily configurable - you can
set it directly on the loop with so
callback duration in seconds on the loop
directly itself so much like some
people's testing philosophies sometimes
we want to debug in production because
why not but usually you don't want
full-on debug mode while in production
so there's a slight way package I'm
called a IOT bug that will log slow
callbacks for you and it also comes with
the ability to report delayed called
calls to stats D if you use stats team
and so that that's all what this library
does so it's super lightweight and quite
handy so you can easily print the stack
of a task if needed
but you do get a lot with async I used
to bug mode and it gives more
information around unhandled exceptions
what are not being thread safe and when
there are slow to complete tasks and if
you want to understand slow tasks while
in production io debug is a lightweight
library that essentially does only that
as we saw with async IOT bugs debug mode
the event loop can already track care
routines that take up too much CPU time
to execute but it might be hard to tell
when it's an anomaly or when or what is
a pattern so a lot of folks might first
reach for a C profile when trying to
understand performance and we can try
that here too but there isn't that much
to glean from this the top item here is
essentially the event loop itself and
even if we looked at our own code
specifically you can kind of get a
picture of what's going on but it
doesn't immediately surface any
bottlenecks or particularly slow areas
of course our main function would have
the most time cumulatively since that's
where the event loop is ran but nothing
is immediately obvious so I recently
discovered K cash grime even though it's
been around for a while but you can use
it with Python and to do so we first
save the output of C profile and then
use this package called PI prof to call
tree which takes the output of C profile
and converts the data into something
that K cash Brian can understand and so
when the script is ran and you're met
with this UI and it's ok if you can't
make anything out but basically on the
left hand side there's a profiling data
that we would otherwise see from the
output of C profile and then the two
sections on there right now shows
information about colors and collies
including a call graph which is on the
bottom and a map of the Khali's which is
on the top if we limit our view to only
our script and like start clicking
around we can start to get an idea of
where time is most spent and the
visualization groups modules together by
color and so when I first ran this
service I notice there's a lot of blue
on the Kali map that's on the top there
and if you click into that blue it's
actually logging that's taking a lot of
time let me go back to that
in a second so cake ask Ryan allows us
to get a broad picture of what's going
on and gives us visual clues of where to
look for potential areas of unnecessary
time spent but then there's a line
profiler package and we can use it to
hone in on areas of our code that we're
suspicious of so after installing the
profiler you can add a profile decorator
where you want to profile here I'm just
decorating the save care routine for now
the line profiler library comes with a
tool called current prof
and that will invoke our script with and
then we render the output line profiler
itself and this is a line by line
assessment of our decorated code the
total time spent in this function is
just over two milliseconds and the
majority of that time was spent in
logging there's something we can do
about that
coincidentally someone has done
something about him there's a package
called AAO logger that allows for
non-blocking logging so if we switched
at a default log area with a logger and
rerun line profiler we can see that our
total time spent in that function has
halved as well as time spent while
logging so certainly these are like
minuscule improvements that we're doing
here it was probably a lot more that we
can do but if you imagine this sort of
on a larger scale we could probably save
a lot of time and also as I see it if we
have an event loop let's try and take
full advantage of it
so we've profiled using C profiler
inline profiler but we had to stop the
service in order to look at results so
perhaps you'd like a live profiler along
with your production testing and
debugging if you do that and there's a
package called profiling that provides
an interactive UI and it supports async
i/o as well as threads and units granted
you can't attach to an already running
process with this particular tool you'll
need to launch a service with it and
when you do you get this text-based UI
that regularly updates you can drill
down you can
well inspecting something and restarted
you're able to save performance data to
view it with this UI at a later time and
also provides the tool provides a server
which you can then remotely connect to
it so the TLDR profiling there isn't
much difference with profiling a single
code from LAN a sink i/o code it can be
a little confusing though with looking
at C profile output to get an initial
picture of your service your services
performance using a suit profiler with K
cache groin can help surface areas to
investigate without that visualization
we saw that it can be a bit difficult to
see the hotspots once you have an idea
of those hotspot areas you can use a
line profiler to get a line-by-line
performance data and finally if you want
to profile a profile in production I
suggest taking a look at the profiling
package so in essence this talk is
something that I would have liked a year
ago speaking to passel in here but I'm
hoping that that there are others who
can benefit from a use case that is not
a web crawler this is the link to the
full blog post the slides and all the
code and I must give my obligatory spiel
where Spotify is hiring for various
engineering and data science positions
at all of our engineering offices
Stockholm London New York and Boston so
if you're interested you can come talk
to me and thank you very much
[Applause]